[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tb 60,18 l'émission à ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
cyclisme en connaît les noms des quatre
pistes art qui partiront jeux olympiques
de tokyo cet été parmi eux un certain
florian gringo du bce sky nous louerons
avec nous dans cette émission
équitation lui aussi devrait participer
aux jeux olympiques dans les prochaines
années victor levêque s'entraîne
désormais à maisons laffitte dans cet
objectif
coup de projecteur ce magazine cyclisme
du 14 au 18 juin quatre cyclistes
amateurs de maurepas vont rallier
manteau en partant de brest objectif
sensibiliser le public et collecter des
dons destinés à la recherche sur les
cancers pédiatriques
les participants sont avec nous dans
cette émission l'actualité sportive
c'est maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ces titres on
va parler de tennis et deux euros l'an à
garros on l'attendait avec impatience
mais on a été finalement déçu arthur
rinderknecht le saint germanois 118e
joueur mondial a perdu contre le croate
marines ilitch dans le top 50 mondial
le score est sévère 7 6 6 1 6 2 en 2h18
de jeu et un premier set en 74 minutes
très accroché évinois a dit en
conférence de presse qu'il n'a pas fait
le match qu'il aurait aimé faire parce
qu'il n'a pas réussi à le faire
le français espère maintenant continuer
à monter au classement lui qui
bénéficiait d'une wild card à roland
garros chez les dames la versaillaise
chloé à pâques et qui a perdu dès le
premier tour face à la polonaise
magdalena tu l'as 251e joueuse mondiale
invité à discuter ces internationaux de
france a été battue en deux sets sur le
score de 6-3 6-3 une nouvelle
désillusion pour les vies noizat n'a
jamais passé le 1er tour de roland
garros depuis sa première participation
en 2017
enfin le troisième événement engagé sur
ces internationaux de france
antoine bibeau dos est lui aussi éliminé
dès le premier tour pour son deuxième
roland-garros chez les jeunes engagés
aujourd'hui sur le tournoi juniors face
à l'américain lille of living droit de
saison qui s'entraîne au comité de
feucherolles n'a pas fait le poids et
s'est inclinée sur le score de 6-2 6-2
il retentera sa chance l'année prochaine
il pourrait encore participer à une
édition junior vu son jeune âge
toujours à roland garros les yvelinois
sont également à présent dans l'immense
contingent des 282 ramasseurs de balle
de la compétition parmi la dizaine
divine war retenu pour cette édition
2021 on retrouve cyprien marins de magny
les hameaux le jeune de 13 ans a
commencé le tennis à l'âge de 5 ans
tennis club de sa ville et il vit
pleinement sa passion porte d'auteuil la
ramasser les balles sur le court à
simone mathieu et sur les annexes il a
notamment été sur des simples hommes et
femmes des matchs junior et des doubles
de tennis fauteuil il a participé au
match john isner et sam querrey et vous
aurez peut-être l'occasion de le voir à
la télévision à cette semaine il
contient ramasser les balles cette
semaine sur cette édition 2021
on va maintenant à parler à cyclisme la
fédération française de cyclisme a
dévoilé le nom à des quatre pistes
harkis sont en lice aux jeux olympiques
de tokyo du 23 juillet au 8 août
on retrouve dans cette équipe m'a t-il
de gros qui disputera la vitesse
individuelle et le
il ya également sébastien biche et ryan
et là les flingues rainbow du vc e sky
une autre piste art sur la sélectionnés
ultérieurement pour nous parler de cette
annonce nous avons avec nous via écran
interposé à flot un grec beau membre de
l'équipe de france et le directeur
technique national de la fff c'est
christophe masle un bon soir bonsoir
alors déjà une première question pour
vous florian comment vous avez appris
cette nouvelle
alors nous on a fait des tests en
interne pour savoir le post 1
du coup je les cieux à partir du moment
où on a réalisé des chronos avec mon
concurrent qui est aussi du vaisseau
skyteam vous sert quentin calero et du
coup une immense joie j'imagine ils
mangent joie une étape de franchie vers
le réel objectif
une carrière sportive de haut niveau qui
est la médaille aux jeux olympiques donc
très content mais il ya encore beaucoup
de travail et pour aller chercher la
plus belle des médailles
justement comment votre entourage a
réagi les jo c'est quand même pas rien
dans une carrière ah c'est sûr c'est pas
rien mon entourage m'a remis quand même
les pieds sur terre dans le sens où ben
comme j'ai dit mon objectif c'est la
médaille donc faut retourner travailler
et elle inquiète à qui donc c'est une
belle sélection mais derrière j'ai
encore beaucoup de travail
alors christophe maintenant est-ce que
sa sélection est pleinement méritée tout
à fait donc le report des jo de juillet
2020 juillet 20 août 2000 e 21 a fait
que la sélection que nous prévoyons
l'année dernière a été complètement
chamboulé puisque greg baugé qui était
notre démarreur attitré de l'équipe a
mis un terme à sa carrière
donc nous avions l'obligation de leur
mise en concurrence de
le démarreur donc c'était lorient à il
était contre quentin caleyron et donc
ils ont été testés afin déjà ils se sont
entraînés là depuis quelques mois de cet
objectif ils ont été testés comme
florian relatifs à c'est lui qui avec et
un temps prêterait les zones europe de
17,36 c'est simple orient avec un temps
de 7 36 qui est équivalent voire
légèrement mieux que ce que faisait greg
baugé ces dernières années donc voilà on
a notre démarreur d'une manière claire
panacée l'exemple du démarreur est clair
et net
c'est compliqué de choisir au dernier
moment comme comme celui là alors le
premier tour c'est je dirais que c'est
assez simple comme florian l'a deviné
qu'il était sélectionné c'est parce que
ça se fait vraiment chrono le premier
tour c'est celui qui faillit pas et il
ne dépend pas des autres après 2 le
deuxième tour dépend de la vitesse avec
elle il énoncé et est lui-même
on voit aussi le temps qui va être et
son 3ème d'eau c'était un peu plus
compliqué sur les jours suivants
d'impatience sur le le la place du
finisseur dont qui s'est jouée entre
rien et la halle et belleville mont
vernon alors c'est une équipe titulaire
et melvin se retrouvent leur emplacement
alors c'est une équipe très jeune je les
dis précédemment ils ont tous une petite
vingtaine à mathilde de gros à 21 ans
sébastien vigier 24 ans florian beau
vous avez 20 ans c'est bien ça si je me
trompe pas et rien hélas le 22 ans est
un avantage ou un inconvénient selon
vous à christophe manas alors c'est un
avantage d'un inconvénient c'est la
meilleure équipe que nous avons donc ce
sont des coureurs qui sont jeunes qui
sont talentueux et je crois que c'est
surtout à davantage dans la préparation
de paris 2024 puisque la entre nos amis
aussi qu'on va fonctionner sur les
olympiades précédente et jusqu'à 2020
avec le des coureurs de l'ancienne
génération et lagat vraiment un tournant
qui est en train de se pendre avec la
halle à la et les jeunes font leur place
des jeunes s'imposer et ces croix
en 2004 certaines avec épaulettes
vous en pensez-quoi florian alors du
coup moi quand j'ai vécu cette sélection
enfin 50 ans qui a lui trente trois ans
si je veux si je dis pas de bêtises
quant à calais ont donc c'était une
bonne concurrence était sain alors la
jeunesse ça apporte entre guillemets une
marge de progression un peu plus
importante
donc je pense que ça peut être que du
bonus pour la suite et est justement
pour pour l'objectif principal qui est
la médaille donc pourquoi pas on parle
beaucoup des jo de 2024 christophe manas
le disais précédemment pour cette
nouvelle génération
il faut vous lancer dès maintenant dans
de grands vins je pense c'est toujours
intéressant de d'avoir des comment dire
pas des opportunités mais des
responsabilités tôt que ce soit dans nos
carrières sportives ou même
professionnel donc non moi je trouve ça
vraiment intéressant de pouvoir goûter à
sa à cet âge là pour justement au mieux
préparé tout le reste est ce que vous
avez l'habitude de 6 ou 6 de vous
préparer ensemble on vous suivez depuis
quelques années tous vous connaissez ce
que c'est un plus justement en vue des
jeux olympiques alors ryan lui ça fait
depuis que j'ai l'âge de 13 ans que je
le connais on est né natif de la même
région
en rhône-alpes donc bah c'est pour moi
c'est une belle histoire c'est c'est mon
pote on vit notre truc et et
qu'aujourd'hui on réalise un peu notre
rêve de gosse qu'on avait quand on était
plus jeunes
pourquoi pas et saufs maintenant c'est
un peu ce que vous recherchez peut-être
vous parliez 2024 mais déjà des ces jo
de créer une ambiance collective au sein
du groupe france alors oui j'ai parlé de
2024 mais bon ce n'est pas qu'une équipe
de jeunes qui va aller en voyage à tokyo
c'est l'équipe de france qui valent à
tokyo dans un objectif de
pour suivre les résultats que l'équipe
de france a obtenu jusque là sur ces
dernières années donc notre objectif est
clairement de monter sur le podium
on a des adversaires très bien des des
hollandais qui semble intouchable pour
la médaille d'or il ya également des
anglais très fort mais bon voilà nous on
est emmené dans ses entrailles d'heure
et est donc l'objectif sur un non
seulement de participer à ces jeunes
coureurs de participer à l'encan
vieillot mais également d'aller chercher
leur première médaille alors la france
avait remporté voulais rajouter quelque
chose face à vanins non j'ai cru alors
la france avaient emporté qu'une seule
médaille de bronze sur piste lors des
derniers jo de rio c'était le plus
mauvais score depuis à 24 ans l'objectif
ce sera forcément de faire mieux
christophe manas oui alors il ya aussi
un peu la dynamique dans laquelle
j'espère vont s'enclencher ces jeux
olympiques pour l'équipe de france en
cyclisme parce que les courses de pièces
vont intervenir à partir du lundi 2 août
et avant ça il y en a eu déjà toutes les
épreuves les épreuves de route les
épreuves de vtt mon viseur on vise
carrément des médias et galtier des
épreuves de bmx ou novices également des
médailles
donc j'espère que les vaincus voilà
cette équipe de le collectif piste sera
dégagée de cette pression de remporter
une médaille de la délégation east en 16
semaines avec et des tice td lte de bmx
et puis donc avec des médailles et des
titres je l'espère est-ce qu'il
permettra de que des pisteurs se
relâcher puisse viser ce qu'ils sont
allés faire c'est à dire une médaille en
vitesse par équipes et puis pour eux les
individuels on n'est pas favoris mais on
revient avec mathilde de gros avec red
bull j'ai appris à bouger pendant avec
celle vigier et et ryan
il ya vraiment des outsiders de détails
vous avez un objectif de médailles ou
pas du tout oui on a toujours des
objectifs à long terme on avait annoncé
il ya très longtemps déjà il ya trois
ans aux six médailles à tokyo on essaie
de garder ce cap
alors il ya des choses on voyait des
médailles qui semblait voulait se
dessiner et dans certaines disciplines
et puis il va là des choses changent
la chance que le vtt nous rassure
beaucoup et on espère faire le carton
plein en vtt
mais on se rend se tient toujours à six
médailles et personnellement si on
pouvait avoir le 2 mai veille sur la
piste une en sprint les pentes à
sélection est annoncé et d'endurance
soleure ce moment avec éventuellement un
titre on fera des bogeys aux attentions
florian à vous avez la pression
bon je pense pas c'est de la bonne
pression parce que comme on dit on est
là pour performer et on n'est pas là
pour pour voyager donc ça ça nous
rappelle que le premier objectif de ce
déplacement de cet événement c'est cette
paire formée d'aller chercher une
médaille dans la question florian qu'est
ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour sergio
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter va je dirais bon courage ans
pas dit mais non plus qu'on convient de
m'encourager que et supporter l'équipe
de france merci à tous les deux d'être
intervenu dans cette émission on suivra
évidemment vos performances avec
attention je vous rappelle les dates des
jo de tokyo ils se dérouleront du 23
juillet au 8 août
lui aussi il compte bien faire les jeux
olympiques
un jour victor l'évêque 22 ans l'une des
plus grandes promesses de l'équitation
en france vient tout juste de déménager
à maisons-laffitte avec ses chevaux
l'illinois a pris ces décisions pour se
préparer au mieux aux grandes échéances
internationales et notamment les jo de
reportage bonjour ses lecteurs l'évêque
bienvenue dans les écuries
arrivé il ya tout juste un mois le
cavalier international de concours
complet se sont déjà chez lui à maisons
laffitte
cette yvelinois pure souche a quitté la
boissière école près de rambouillet pour
des
ménagé avec sept de ses chevaux décision
mûrement réfléchie
il y avait un aspect géographique
puisque je suis sur la fin de mes études
à sciences po voilages intègre un master
marketing et société était importante
pour moi
pour terminer les deux ans qui me reste
de me rapprocher un peu de paris y avait
aussi la nécessité de voilà me recentrer
un peu plus sur mes chevaux de
compétition j'ai amené que mes jeux faut
vraiment de haut niveau à
maisons-laffitte c'était aussi un choix
personnel
voilà je partage cette passion et ce
sport avec ma copine et puis voilà
c'était je pense important et
intéressant de nous entraîner ensemble
avec cette installation le cavalier de
22 ans espère également trouver un cadre
de vie propice à la pratique de
l'équitation tous les jours victor
l'évêque va s'entraîner dans cette ville
baptisée la cité du cheval en raison de
son importante activité équestre et de
son hippodrome
je crois que ça offre des perspectives
d'entraînement exceptionnel c'est ce que
je recherche aussi avant tout c'est la
possibilité de pouvoir avoir accès aux
pistes avoir accès à la forêt et puis
aussi tous les arts de travail l'écart
de dressage l'écart à d'obstacles
essentiel évidemment à la pratique de
manse par haut niveau une ville qui lui
permettra peut-être d'accéder à ses plus
grands rêves avec notamment en ligne de
mire les jeux olympiques de 2024
une compétition dans laquelle
l'yvelinois espère briller après avoir
remporté quatre titres de champion
d'europe chez les jeunes ce sera je
l'espère mes premiers jeux olympiques
j'ai beaucoup entendu dire que voilà les
jeux olympiques c'est une atmosphère
très différente
on dit souvent qu'il faut aussi mesurer
une première fois avant d'être
performant on verra j'essaierai de
préparer de la meilleure manière
possible
et puis si j'y vais oui je me battrai à
tout prix pour une médaille une médaille
olympique viendrait valider de belle
manière ce choix de déménager à
maisons-laffitte maintenant un place au
travail
en golf antoine ros nord n'a pas
démérité lors du mémorial tournament le
golfeur du racing club de france à la
boulie termine à une très belle 18e
place du prestigieux tournoi américain
il a bouclé son dernier tour en plus de
au dessus du par mais il peut nourrir
quelques regrets il a réalisé un boguey
au trou numéro deux et un quadruple au
numéro 3 vinoy termine finalement au
même niveau que des cadors du circuit
comme le beau comme brian 200 veaux ou
rory mcilroy
le tournoi a lui été remporté par
l'américain patrick quand les antoine
runner devrait maintenant revenir en
europe pour la suite de sa saison
une saison qui ne devrait pas passé par
le golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'open de
france ne devrait pas avoir lieu cette
année
déjà reporté en avril dernier à cause de
la crise sanitaire le tournoi devrait
tout simplement être annulée et reportée
à la saison 2022
la raison le tour européen n'arrive
toujours pas à trouver une date
satisfaisant dans le cadre calendrier
pour programmer le rendez vous les
organisateurs doivent avoir plusieurs
mois de visibilité pour programmer
l'événement sauf retournement de
situation de dernière minute les joueurs
se retrouveront sur les greens de
l'albatros l'année prochaine pour
participer à cette 104e édition attendue
depuis deux ans un mot de voile à
présent louis burton est actuellement
engagés sur la course aussi au cnrs au a
peu l'occasion pour le grand public de
découvrir son nouveau bateau bureau
vallée 3a bateau avec lequel il faudra
le prochain vendée globe en 2024
le rendez vous est l'occasion pour les
lillois de le tester pour l'instant
laurent politain terminé 5e de la
première étape entre lorient et cascais
il est actuellement 4e sur le de la
deuxième étape entre cascais et alicante
la fin de la course est programmé aux
alentours du 15 juin à genève on
continue par du cyclisme du 14 au 18
juin quatre cyclistes amateurs du
vélo-club de maurepas vont rallier
manteau en partant de brest l'objectif
est de sensibiliser le grand public et
collecter des dons destinés à la
recherche sur les cancers pédiatriques
pour nous parler de ce projet fou nous
avons avec nos envies
olivier a dit joue donc dit good est le
promoteur et philippe mariani l'un des
participants bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
michael alors comment vous sentez vous à
quelques jours du départ tout simplement
parfaite forme on a terminé notre
entraînement lourd on va dire samedi
dernier par un vent de 100 km qui s'est
très bien passé voilà au forum ont aidé
un patient maintenant de prendre le
départ déjà de gagner le reste regagné
brest et puis puis de nous élancer pour
ce que beau périple de 2 5 jours en
traversant la france de brest à menton
alors avant de parler de la course et
des conditions titanesque qui vous
attendent
olivier et qu'est ce que est ce qu'on
peut parler du cyclo cancer qu'est ce
que c'est concret tant la sig le cancer
c'est d'abord une association créée en
2014 par patrice martin il a vocation
effectivement la collecte de dons pour
la lutte contre le cancer et
l'accompagnement également des personnes
atteintes de cette marche et
hospitaliers depuis 2014 donc on a pu
réaliser plusieurs événements
historiquement en normandie
et puis en 2019 on a commencé à
délocaliser la seaco cancer grâce au
club de maurepas club de maurepas on a
rencontré des gens totalement investi
dans la cause qui nous ont accompagnés
qu'ils nous ont soutenus qui aujourd'hui
n'en sommes à philippe continue
effectivement nous accompagner et la
zone pour laquelle on va les soutenir
aussi aux cubains de ce périple a donc
1400 km 1400 km estime entre rester
m'entends vont nous permettre de
travailler
l'imputation la renommée de la cip le
cancer est également de le connecter des
droits philippe pourquoi vous vous êtes
lancé dans défi vous personnellement m'a
déjà parce qu'on est très sensible à la
cause on l'a été dès en 2019 lorsque la
première cyclo cancer organisée par nos
repas a eu lieu on a vu tous ses enfants
avec le sourire accroché aux lèvres
lorsqu'on leur a menti représenter le
dont on a réussi à faire et les
perspectives que cela augurait pour eux
donc on a été très sensible à leurs
réactions on est aussi plusieurs à être
touchés de près ou de loin par par la
maladie donc tous ces éléments réunis en
fait qu'on naturellement lorsqu'on a
décidé de faire cette épreuve entre
brest et les mentons sediba plutôt que
de pédaler
simplement on va essayer de pédaler
utile et essayer de ramener un peu des
fonds pour améliorer le quotidien de ces
enfants et enfin alors accrocher un
sourire alors à leur visage est-ce que
tout est prêt à quelques jours du départ
où il y a encore d'être des zones
d'ombré on sait penser par exemple vous
n'allez pas dormir à l'hôtel c'est bien
ça oui alors au niveau de l'hôtel on
l'avait envisagé cette solution au
départ mais avec l'épreuve la
problématique copie de 19 c'était très
compliqué notamment dès qu'on arrivait
en ardèche et sur la côte d'azur
beaucoup d'hôtels n'ont pas résisté
malheureusement certains ont fermé donc
impossibilité de nous loger
donc la solution va nous est venue de
louer un grand camping car qui va être
conduit par deux personnes du club
également qu'ils vont nous faire
l'assistance donc ça ça a été très très
bien préparer la logistique est très
bien pensé le point de départ le point
d'arrivée les zones de repas les zones
de collecte de fonds qu'on va faire
mutuellement avec avec olivier ou là où
va aller à la rencontre des habitants
des institutionnels des généreux
donateurs qu'on va un petit peu croisé
partout sur notre chemin
les clubs vont venir à notre rencontre
notamment le club de carhaix qui s'est
manifestée en premier qui va nous ouvrir
100 local dès 6 heures du matin le lundi
pour un petit un petit café
nouvelle chauffer de la nuit qu'on aura
passé dans les monts d'arrée et puis
après je pense qu'on va poursuivre par
des expériences identique tout au long
du parcours ça ça va être la surprise on
a lancé l' on a lancé l'idée olivier a
fait beaucoup de communication puis
maintenant on va voir on va voir le
résultat
on espère avoir beaucoup de monde sans
misère 110 heures de vélo c'est ça
pendant pendant la compétition
alors en fait on a délai pour couvrir
ses 1400 km et ses seize mille mètres de
dénivelé on a un délai d' 116 heures
maximum en fait une diagonale c'est une
épreuve officielle qu'on a un petit peu
dérouté puisque normalement on n'a pas
le droit d'être assistée là là pour le
coup on peut pas ne pas être assistés
puisqu'on n'a pas d'hôtel donc on aura
un camping car qui va nous suivre qui
que l'on retrouvera pour le midi et pour
le soir uniquement il ne suivra pas tout
le long du parcours est en fait laissant
les on pense met à peu près une centaine
d'heures et on se garde 16h de sécurité
au cas où on est de nombreuses avaries
notamment les crevaisons c'est assez
fréquent et puis des dédicaces de rayon
saut de chaîne
et puis d'autres d'autres événements
qu'on n'apprenne pas aujourd'hui et qui
peuvent nous arriver sur la route donc
on gagne petit sécurité donc on va faire
à peu près entre 15 et 17 heures de vélo
jours en partant tous les jours aux
alentours de 3h du matin et on va
s'arrêter vers 19h30 20h voilà olivier
on est d'accord l'ensemble des dons vont
aller à la recherche contre le cancer on
est d'accord on est complètement
d'accord
c'est la vocation effectivement de la
team six concerts président patrice
martin tient effectivement l'ensemble
des sommes versées collectés sont
intégralement reversés et transformé en
dons alors cette année ils vont être
versés également à l'hôpital nous
prémunir
aïe c'est une opération que l'on va
répéter à nouveau que l'on a déjà
effectué au moins deux ans
il ya deux ans en 2019 il y avait permis
lâcher de tablettes électroniques et la
réalisation de vidéos dédramatiser les
soins dédramatiser l'entrée dans
l'hôpital des enfants
donc pour les accompagner et c'est plat
n'est effectivement pas un objectif de
collecte de dons je peux déjà affirmer
que les 50% déjà été atteint on entend
des efforts à faire ces efforts allaient
réaliser une phase où le terrain puisque
ça a été quasiment 200 clubs sur la
diagonale qui ont été contactés
c'était une des étapes ville à demeurer
qui vont nous accompagner dans une
communication événement auprès de la
population fin du grand public
on va avoir du monde on part collecter
encore et encore et les dons vont venir
effectivement cours par exemple l'achat
de vélos vélos d'appartement pour les
enfants ça permet de le maintien du
tissu musculaire à permet de gagner à
boire repos réparateur de travail et un
d'éliminer le coupé il faut qu'on avance
dans l'émission en tout cas le message
est passé merci olivier merci philippe
bon courage à vous deux merci d'être
terminée dans cette émission et bon
courage qu'on sait à 1400 kilomètres on
espère que vous aurez une belle météo
philippe c'est beaucoup alors on va
maintenant parler rugby à partir de la
rentrée prochaine le club de plaisir va
ouvrir une académie à destination des
jeunes de 16 à 23 ans des journées de
détection sont programmés ce mercredi et
samedi de 14h à 17h au stade robert
barran on écoute sébastien inrocks ali
l'un des concepteurs du projet c'est
notre interview express
[Musique]
alors cette académie sera ouverte pour
des jeunes âgés de 16 à 23 ans ont des
morts par des journées de détection la
semaine prochaine 9 et le 12
donc il s'agira de former les jeunes sur
le plan sportif mais également d'avoir
un suivi scolaire et médical donc on va
leur proposer un programme pouvant aller
de 5 à à 12 heures en plus des séances
collectives sur la semaine avec un vrai
contenu heures rugbystique et ce sera
vraiment tourner sur l'individuel voilà
le développement individuel sportif et
bien sûr sans oublier le le développe le
développement professionnel pour qu'ils
acquièrent une qualification
professionnelle à la sortie l'objectif
c'est de former nos
nos jeunes joueurs et joueuses au plus
haut niveau bien sûr pour alimenter
notre équipe seniors filles et garçons
puisque on avoue on ouvre cette année
une équipe féminine mais également de
pouvoir les amener au plus haut niveau
donc s'ils vont au dessus de notre
niveau tant mieux c'est notre travail
aussi notre ambition alors c'est un
projet qu'on parle depuis quelques
années effectivement avec le président
et puis qu'on a mis en marche
on a décidé de mettre en marche at elle
cette année principalement dûe à
l'activité très minime qu'on a eu on
s'est dit voilà pourquoi pourra
travailler sur ce projet c'est déjà la
fin de cette émission merci d'avoir
suivi à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]